merci bonsoir on m'a demandé de venir
parler d'éducation qui vous savez quand
on parle d'éducation c'est toujours un
peu cheap parce que tout le monde
connaît l'éducation parce que tout le
monde est allé à l'école le problème
c'est souvent ces convois l'éducation en
fonction de on était quand on est allé à
l'école
qu'est ce qu'on voudrait changer quand
on nous on était à l'école alors que si
on met en application ce que l'on
voudrait qu'ils avaient dû changer à
l'époque où on était là on passe un peu
à côté parce que les enfants de 15 ans
ne seront plus au même endroit donc
quand on parle de changement en
éducation il faut toujours penser
probablement une génération d'avancé
pour les changements qui s'en viennent
le deuxième élément c'est que je veux
que je veux dire avant de commencer
c'est qu'il se fait des choses
extraordinaires au niveau d'éducation au
québec dans le système actuel
il ya des gens qui sont passionnés qui
oeuvre auprès des enfants qui font des
choses fantastiques avec les moyens
qu'ils ont et dans le système
un client autre chose je veux pas faire
une critique du système d'éducation
actuelle donc ce que je vais vous
présenter comme denis ce que je vais
vous dire ce soir c'est pas des éléments
pour critiquer le système en place mais
c'est beaucoup plus pour servir de base
pour savoir quel est donc l'avenir de
notre système d'éducation en général pas
seulement au québec mais un peu partout
dans le monde je vais vous donner 4
données sur la réussite des données le
milieu socioéconomique de vous venez
détermine votre futur propension à
réussir au niveau du système scolaire
dont
dépendamment de milieux
socio-économiques vous amener ya une
influence sur votre cheminement votre
sexe indique votre pension a réussi
plutôt au niveau des habiletés sociales
troisième élément va de santé si vous
êtes en santé si vous arrivez reçu de
bons soins vous avez une meilleure
prévention a réussi troisième élément
l'éducation de vos parents si vos
parents sont scolarisés vous avez une
meilleure chance de réussite
ces quatre éléments là c'est des
éléments appuyé par la recherche donc
c'est ce que les recherches de 10 par
rapport à la réussite scolaire
ce qui signifie que si vous êtes issu
d'une famille à faible revenu si vous
êtes un garçon
désolé pour les gars sont dans la salle
si vous avez un problème de santé vous
avez des victimes de maltraitance ou
encore si vous avez des parts un peu et
puis il ya des bonnes chances que vous
ne finissiez pavot pour votre formation
scolaire
c'est assez gardant un système qu'on
veut on veut un jour un système qu'on
veut re existe réalisé aujourd'hui où
l'on est la réalité
je vous donne d'autres chez 35 % des
enfants sur l'île de montréal
une vulnérabilité dans l'un des cinq 5
éléments développe les cinq éléments de
développement je les donne en rafale
santé physique et bien-être des
compétences sociales donc deuxième
élément on parle de la maturité
affective
donc des enfants qui ont des difficultés
à laisser leurs parents on a déjà vu ça
au développement cognitif et langagier
est habilité de communication et les
connaissances en général ça veut dire
que 35 % des enfants de l'île de
montréal qui est une province qui est
une province on n'est pas entièrement
d'ici 35 % des enfants qui rentrent à
l'école
ces niveaux là ce que ça donne notre
système d'éducation actuelle échoue pour
un élève sur cinq
ça c'est les données de 2015 il ya 20%
des enfants qui rentrent dans le système
d'éducation scolaire actuellement qui ne
finiront pas leur secondaire 5 dans les
temps prévus
je sais pas si ça vous allume quelque
chose moi si j'allais à la clinique on
me disait que dans cette mini club il ya
une chance sur cinq pour comme soir je
pense que jérémy clain si la prochaine
fois que vous mettez votre lettre à la
poste que le facteur ou d'une chance sur
5 pour cent se rendent pas destination
je suis pas certaine que vous utiliserez
ce système là
donc comment ce que ça serait que ce
système leur fonctionne encore et qu'on
accepte que ce système soit toujours en
place
donc il y à 50 m à l'époque du rapport
parent que vous avez connu à l'époque 50
on à démocratiser l'école on a décidé
que l'école était là pour tout ce que
tout le monde avait accès à l'école par
tonton oublié quelque chose de très
important
on a oublié de démocratiser la coupe
sage c'est pas parce qu'on va à l'école
qu'on va apprendre et c'est pas parce
qu'on va à l'école qu'on va finir avec
un dit long qu'est ce que la réussite
scolaire dont comment dans les grandes
villes et les pays
comment est ce qu'on va faire dans les
systèmes pour calculer la réussite
scolaire on se base sur deux choses
premier élément le rendement si vos
résultats au bulletin ça c'est des
rendements à court terme
l'autre élément ce qu'on veut c'est le
cas on va parler du on va parler du de
la diplomation ça c'est la réussite de
votre diplôme de secondaire 5 ce sont
les deux éléments sur lequel on se base
pour dire que le système scolaire
fonctionne ou pas pour dire que vous
avez ou non réussi votre diplomation
vous avez réussi à passer au travers le
système scolaire
on peut comprendre le sens bien dans ces
deux éléments la doc on parle de
résultats scolaires
on parle de résultats des examens
compris qu'ils sont utilisés pour
arriver et à il l'identifié c'est les
gens qui pensent et qui pensent que
quelles perspectives on donne pourquoi
on dit aux gens qu'il faut aller à
l'école aujourd'hui
moi j'en ai cinq que je vais vous donner
c'est des perspectives économiques
habituellement on va dire c'est pour
accéder à des sources secondaires
vous allez à l'école primaire et
secondaire pour aller à l'université
allez dire ça un élève de maternelle
pas sûr que pour lui ça a beaucoup de
cendres dedans à l'université on va dire
que c'est pour obtenir des revenus plus
élevés pour augmenter votre chance
d'avoir des revenus plus élevés qu'à
vous allez sortir on va dire que c'est
pour contribuer à l'essor économique du
pays pour ce que ça vaut
on va dire que c'est pour engendrer des
coûts moindres pour les temps parce
qu'on sait que les gens plus instruites
coûte moins cher au niveau des services
sociaux on va parler de toi on va parler
de l'individu ou la collectivité
donc c'est des raisons vraiment
économies qu'on va donner pour faire un
centre pour expliquer pourquoi est ce
que c'est important aujourd'hui d'aller
à l'école je vous donne deux autres
éléments j'appelle ça moi les équations
de la prospérité
mais ce qu'on nous dit au niveau général
de
d'un économiste que j'ai beaucoup aimé
l'elysée lui pour renforcer la
prospérité dans le star des systèmes
économiques
c'est l'éducation si on élève le niveau
d'éducation et de formation
on a une croissance économique à long
terme
donc après avoir quelque chose au niveau
et que deux mais qui est meilleur pour
les hommes d'avoir les gens les plus
instruits possible en 1999 le ministère
de l'éducation publié de revue qui n'est
plus disponible mais dont j'ai un grand
copie et qui expliquait que le niveau
d'éducation élevé et un mauvais
rendement fiscal plus élevé pour l'état
par exemple quelqu'un qui finit pas son
secondaire 5 va offrir un rendement de 6
mois de donner un rendement fiscal à
l'état de 300 milles par l auf au terme
de sa de sa vie en tant qu au terme
d'une d'une vie il va avoir rapporté 3,5
milles au niveau fiscal quelqu'un qui va
à l'université je vous le donne en
chiffres allez-vous l'idée rémy lyon
donc quelqu'un qui exempte d'études
universitaires va rapporter à l'état 1
million alors quand on dit qu'on finance
pas assez les études universitaires il
ya un rendement qui est associé quand
même à ce qui semble à mon avis à cet
égard plus le niveau d'éducation est
élevé moins les coûts sont élevés en
matière de services publics les gens
éduqués ya moins de criminalité
les gens vont utiliser - les services de
santé les gens vont utiliser - les
services sociaux
ce que je veux dire aux partis de st on
parle beaucoup dans ce cas si l'on en
parle quoi un courant qu'encore d'enjeux
humains
en tout cas moi j'en ai pas entendu
beaucoup dans les recherches que j'ai
regardé les finalités actuel de notre
système d'éducation et à notre roi
on parle des screens socialiser
qualifier c'est ce qui est écrit dans le
programme de formation des ministères on
veut faire des gens l'objectif du
système actuel c'est de faire apprendre
les gens le mot plaisir d'apprendre et
là deux fois dans le programme de
formation du ministère de l'éducation au
niveau du primaire
les deux endroits où il est c'est en
maternelle et dans une des compétences
transversales pour ne veux plus entendre
pourtant le plaisir à prendre cette
année les mains qui me semble important
on vise la réussite de tous donc le
système est fait pour viser la
résistance dans un système qui est une
et c'est la même machine à saucisses
pour tout le monde on veut sortir enfin
les gens et tout le monde doit réussir
est ce qu'on veut si minimiser les
impacts économiques à différents niveaux
autant au niveau des individus au niveau
de la société
alors je reviens avec ma question
qu'en est il des anges et humaine et
donc le système actuel voix contre la
lecture
à mon avis même de l'apprentissage mais
surtout du plaisir qui pourrait être
attaché quittait qui permettrait par
exemple de faire émerger une motivation
aux gens de vouloir parce que dans le
fond ce qu'on voudrait c'est ce qu'on
voudrait c'est qu'on voudra va susciter
chez les gens le goût d'amande brésil et
motivation là ça veut pas dire que c'est
une absence défense avait pas dire que
c'est de la facilité vous et moi je suis
rendu au doctorat c'est si difficile
mais je suis motivé à y aller parce que
j'ai des motivations qui m'appartiennent
même chose pour la maîtrise que j'ai
fait j'avais des motivations à faire
cette maîtrise là à poursuivre mes
études universitaires
mais je peux vous dire il faut au niveau
du primaire ou du secondaire
j'ai haï l'école j'ai détesté l'école je
me suis d'abord des écoles soient plus
particulier que je sois devenu directeur
essayer d'autres choses
donc quel avenir pour l'éducation
c'était le sujet qu'on m'ait demandé de
couvrir ce qu'on me demande de couvrir
donc je vais vous donner quelques
éléments
les enfants d'aujourd'hui vous avez des
enfants vous apprendre des hadjis lille
mais je vais vous annoncer quelque chose
dont vous êtes trop d'années ce qui
était bonne le code de notre génération
et nous le monde qui est à l'extérieur
change à une vitesse tellement important
beaucoup plus importante qu'elle a
changé pour nous donc défi au niveau de
l'école a préparé ces gens là pour ça il
faut donc à mon avis
l'école de l'avenir complètement repensé
les finalités notre système par exemple
système permettait d'adapter
l'apprentissage à chaque enfant
imaginons les systèmes comme ça
imaginons fait le plaisir d'apprendre ce
serait un des objectifs imaginons que la
motivation était un des objectifs du
système
imaginons qu ici le rythme
d'apprentissage des enfants ne dépend
des prix de l'âge des enfants
pourquoi tous les enfants qui ont le
même âge qui apprennent pas toutes à la
même vitesse sont toutes dans la même
classe
c'est un peu particulier mais le système
fonctionne comme ça il faut donc falloir
trois concerts le concept
d'apprentissage d'éducation et d'écoles
qui sont des concepts différents et
qu'on mélange des fois souvent le
système actuel système de pédagogie de
la gouvernance qui a quelqu'un qui
enseigne les gens les gens vont recevoir
ces éléments là ils vont régurgiter ces
éléments là pour obtenir le diplôme et
pourra tenir leur place leur
participation dans une société c'est un
système
warsage fait dans le même système pour
tout le monde ça c'est pas moi c'est
foucault qui disait ça que j'aime
beaucoup
l'apprentissage c'est pas une
acquisition d'un objet qu'on mesure
quand on parle d'accueil
quand on parle d'apprentissage c'est là
c'est l'acquisition de pouvoir d'agir
quand on a assez pour faire quelque
chose pour soi pour faire quelque chose
pour quelqu'un c'est une action
qu'on fait sur soi même j'peux pas fait
attendre quelqu'un qui veut pas
l'apprentissage par de nous donc irene
les mains qui est important au niveau de
la motivation
c'est une suite d'essais et d'erreurs
aussi alors apprendre c'est se tromper
ce qui n'est pas à mon avis à celles du
système solaire l'apprentissage est inné
vous avez appris à marcher vous n'êtes
pas allés à l'école pour le marché vous
avez appris à parler vous avez vibré à
jouer quand vous avez un nouveau jeu
vidéo vous avez pas besoin de lire les
instructions pour savoir comment jouer
intuitivement vous allez apprendre à
utiliser puisque vous avez vous allez
apprendre mais youn et les mains qui est
important vous avez une propension
naturelle à prendre si vous y est motivé
la motivation devrait donc avec le point
de départ de tous les systèmes qui vise
l'apprentissage en partie pendant
d'éducation aujourd'hui c'est un système
institutionnalisé pour apprendre et
développer ce qu'on appelle des
habiletés sociales ce qui est important
à prendre c'est quelque chose qu'on fait
collectivement il ya un élément
collectif à mon avis qui est important
mais ce système donne est complètement
ébranlé aujourd'hui par les élèves à
besoins particuliers
je trouve ça cruel on appelle ça des
élèves à besoins particuliers
c'est des gens qui sont non conformes
dans le système actuel
ça veut dire qu'il fait pas dans le
système et on voit les équipes et élèves
à besoins particuliers
c'est peut-être que le système est pas
capable de s'occuper des enfants et non
pour que les enfants sont particuliers
alors vraiment on demande aujourd'hui à
ce système là on attend on a une
obligation de résultat ont tous une
obligation de moyens vous savez un
médecin il ya une obligation de moyens
il doit faire tout en son 9
pour soigner un patient si le patient
meurt à la fin il y aura essayé tout ce
qu'ils voulaient le système d'éducation
était comme ça au début il a été pensé
comme ça au début mais aujourd'hui on
veut des résultats
et malheureusement le système a pas
changé donc quelque chose qui fonctionne
pas dans cet élément dont l'éducation au
delà du fait que c'est accessible à tous
il faudrait que ce soit un droit pour
chacun à développer son plein potentiel
selon ses capacités
l'école quand on parle de l'école c'est
un lieu important pour l'associer
socialisation studio qui doit rester
important pour la société socialisation
mais c'est un monopole actuellement de
l'apprentissage et je suis désolé mais
c'est un service de garde et sexualité
c'est une analyse et si mes enfants à
l'école trois jours par semaine
qu'est ce qu'on ferait avec eux les deux
autres journées alors lieu un élément
aussi sociétal où on utilise l'école
aussi parce qu'on veut que les parents
travaillent aussi et rapporte aussi des
revenus et rapporte aussi des
d'actionner les maquis cette hauteur là
ici on voyait l'école comme un
environnement plutôt que maximum ici
l'école institutions et des comme un
port d'attache bon endroit où on va
aller nécessairement tous les jours mais
un port d'attache où l'élève qui vise
vraiment sur le supporter dans ses
apprentissages à lui
et si apprentissage ne se passait pas
uniquement à l'école si on avait donc
lieu pour apprendre qui serait
complémentaire à l'école l'enjeu réel à
mon avis du système actuel et de ce
qu'on fait aujourd'hui on a une
éducation et si on veut repenser leur
nid c'est beau de vouloir changer de
système pour le bénéfice des enfants
mais plutôt de changer au système qui
convient au système actuel
donc actuellement le système fonctionne
pour les adultes
donc est-ce qu'on peut changer ce
système là pour le bien des enfants
je suis pas toujours certain je peux pas
finir la conférence en parler
technologie parce que c'est quelque
chose qui m'est très profond qui
étaient-ils vraiment avec ce que j'ai
fait tout au long de ma carrière
ce qui a changé aujourd'hui et ce qui je
pense va faire changer ébranlé les
temples du les systèmes éducatifs
c'est l'arrivée des appareils mobiles
intelligents l'internet des objets
l'internet partout en tout temps
l'accès à des connaissances voilà un
sage a des connaissances de partout on
axait de n'importe où
la capacité de stockage des serveurs sa
engouement dans une vitesse
exponentielle la capacité de calcul des
processeurs on est capable de faire des
calculs qu'on n'était pas capable de
faire et penser à mes yeux 10,1 et sari
avec la capacité des données moi
j'appelle sort ok on garde rapidement
aujourd'hui ce qu'on peut faire
on peut prévoir les épidémies jeu sa
fonction des recherches qui se passe
dans une région donnée
on peut personnaliser les publicités
vous le savez d'ailleurs personnaliser
les publicités sur facebook en fonction
de ce que vous aimez on peut faire un
service quotidien 'aujourd'hui du
diamètre et on peut proposer une vie à
part variable
c'est assez incroyable ce qu'on arrive à
faire on peut prévoir des jugements de
cour de magistrats afin que le juge se
prononce
on prend ça dans un logiciel on passe
des arguments dans un logiciel et on est
capable d'avoir un jugement qui pourrait
être entériné par le juge mais qui
arrive à la même décision que le juge
et pourquoi est ce que cette technologie
leur serait pas au service de
l'éducation au souffre aussi avec des
limites du court central
c'est ce que l'utilisation des données
il ya des choses à faire attention mais
l'intelligence artificielle au service
de l'éducation l'intelligence sociale
ces deux choses c'est des données etc
des algorithmes
deux éléments l'intelligence assistants
d'éducation pourrait faire deux choses
permettent l'émergence de ce qu'on
appelle l'apprentissage yachts et par
les données en anglais
si vous avez pas encore entendu parler
de ça ça existe depuis dix ans mais
c'était trop compliqué de générer des
données
aujourd'hui les données sont au bout de
nos doigts ça permettrait d'émerger
aussi une pédagogie piloté par les
données data driven pédagogie qui est
aussi quelque chose qui quitta en
essence actuellement qui est en
effervescence dans le monde actuellement
et donc l'objectif de tout ça c'est
d'adapter les tâches d'apprentissage au
profil de chaque apprenant imaginer
utiliser la force des algorithmes et des
données afin d'accompagner chacun des
enfants à l'école chacun feint de façon
personnalisée dans son cheminement
scolaire en identifiant ses difficultés
en identifiant ses forces qui lui
permettent un cheminement en fonction de
ses besoins mais surtout pour garder sa
motivation et le plaisir d'argent quel
avenir pour l'éducation c'était la
question de départ je vous donne fini
revoir ni finalité de notre système
d'éducation
ce qu'il arrivait de chaque apprenant de
chaque enfant
entretenir la motivation et le plaisir
d'apprendre parce que quand on aime on
est motivés c'est pas mal plus facile
d'être en mode d'apprentissage repenser
l'école quand je dis repenser l'école là
c'est comme un environnement dynamique
alors vraiment un carrefour de
l'apprentissage la socialisation cet
aspect là doit rester l'école doit
rester
évidemment m à pois fil intelligents
essentielle les nouvelles technologies
puis l'idée c'est de se porter et de
personnaliser les apprentissages que je
pense qu'aujourd'hui la houle à moulins
en ligne il faut se rendre la
personnaliser ces éléments l'homme ici
même au delà la délivrance des diplômes
la fin du secondaire s'est développé
chez tous nos enfants
là le plaisir est là puisque de toute
façon les enfants d'aujourd'hui devront
continuer à 1 pour le restant de leur
vie
je vous remercie de vous